[Music]
weakly be what's up episode 7 if you
[ __ ] love boats as much as I do
you're gonna love this episode I want to
talk about so no self love just some
around there you know just so like
what's so amusing it's like I you know
what you're saying what you're really
saying is if you aren't your biggest fan
if you're not your number-one own fan
you gotta know something shot that's
what it is like like what people
understand is like once you once you
cross that chasm for self esteem like
once you're about yourself you don't
give a [ __ ] and the key is pro or con
when you don't hear the cheering or the
booing you've won because once you're
addicted to the [ __ ] clapping then
the naysaying
got equal leverage you know what I mean
like real positivity is with yourself
not the [ __ ] motivational [ __ ] I post
or like you know or your friend that's
like bright that's great but that's only
like that's only like an injection you
know what I mean you're good for a
minute but then you go back to your own
place and until it's in your own [ __ ]
dome up until you're [ __ ] clapping
for yourself and I'm on some delusion
[ __ ] because we're gonna delusional
you've lost like ruling not on some like
oh you tried it's okay cuz it's not cuz
you're trying to win it's finding that
balance between left and right pulling
for both
but yeah man I believe in that [ __ ] so
much like being your biggest fan is
[ __ ] everything but also respecting
the market the [ __ ] we were talking
about earlier you know like I'm my
biggest fan I think I'm gonna win every
[ __ ] time but when I don't like that
[ __ ] lost what about what about
people who do you think about to be
famous people like people like the
thought of it but it's [ __ ] work you
know like it sounds good on paper sounds
good on paper you know what's funny
people will say it this is actually back
for the first [ __ ] part of this
people will say it but they actually
don't mean it in their head actually I
think more people hold themselves back
they're big they can actually do it I
think there's more people that can
actually do it we're just happy like
when I hear rich and famous now it's
funny you just said those two words and
literally my head I'm like happy because
you know this now - there's unlimited
[ __ ] who are rich and famous
and are unhappiest but sad as [ __ ] money
and fame expose you they speed up the
process right period if you're happy
you're about to get real [ __ ] happy
if you're sad you're about to get real
[ __ ] sad you're not guaranteed after
news it's and it's sound and you know
how it is I get these comments
constantly people like ok bet but I'd
rather be crying in my Bentley
and I laughed at that [ __ ] I'm like cuz
you don't understand because when you
get to that moment when you've got a gun
in your mouth sitting in your [ __ ]
Bentley and what's 13 zeros and your
bank account you don't give a [ __ ]
people don't have empathy for other
people they don't know the biggest issue
is not having like where people get
caught is not having anything or having
too much they're the same side of the
coin
100% yeah but back like if you're not
positive for yourself it's pretty much a
wrap and the biggest thing I try to tell
people that are like when they hear that
they hit me up sometimes I gotta get
interesting DM they're like yo you tell
me not to listen to anybody else but
what if I'm telling myself I'm a piece
of [ __ ] I'm like the answer to that
always is
you aren't somebody put that in your
[ __ ] head and you accepted it you're
pessimistic father put that in your head
your older sister who hates life put
that in your head
somebody instilled that [ __ ] in your
head the second you realize that you
don't hate yourself somebody else put
that in your head the second you starts
carving that [ __ ] out of your brain like
some cancer if you are [ __ ] on
yourself that is not your natural state
you are not born or built to actually
think you [ __ ] suck you don't you've
actually parroted you know parrot like
Johnny Mann in you know nothing you've
parented somebody else's voice so many
of you unfortunately are in ecosystems
of family members and people close to
you who've built in security in you from
the get and I am here to [ __ ] take it
out I am here to take it out my friend
you don't [ __ ] suck you're [ __ ]
awesome
you need to carve that [ __ ] out of your
brain from the ground and so they come
and
begone ride took this sunset into this
time all in time sounds list of those
three a few companies good Microsoft
well I think Microsoft needs to look
back at what happened with Playstation
when they went excuse me with Xbox when
they kind of went outside of where you
expected them to go and execute it
extremely well in a way they went and I
think the acquisition of LinkedIn was a
win I think that's when I think the
company's pretty hot and so right now I
would you know I would be looking at OTT
like why can't Microsoft be a
significant competitor today Amazon
Prime Kulu like like I think M is like a
huge OTT platform they've got plenty of
money when you own LinkedIn you could do
a huge CNBC like world of just LinkedIn
when you own Xbox you can do a huge
original programming just on eSports so
my hot take for them is start an OTT
call at the M triple down on eSports and
business and I'm sure they own a ton of
their [ __ ] that I don't even know that
would do really well and I think it
would be the kind of thing that all of a
sudden think about how it works with
their homework now they got the surface
right or things of that nature
now you've got like a you've got your
house of cards you've got your big hit
and now it's now the original but now
you've got people [ __ ] on it it's the
best series and now season two's
exclusively on the surface and they're
using content to drive your hardware
business
um so I don't I only have surface level
knowledge of Watson but Watson feels to
me like a true election Google home
competitor like I feel like they could
make a voice device thing where they can
humanize the Watson like maybe the
device looks like a face Max Headroom
you might be too young for that guys but
google it and so for me
IBM's places if Watson so smart why not
make the voice device play because I
think that will be one of the biggest
biggest plays and they I be M can do to
Google and Microsoft and Amazon and
Facebook what they did to them with the
winning voice Samsung Samsung was so
dangerously close to winning I don't
think people understand how much they
use [ __ ] with that right before the
phone went on fire it was right there
and I still think deep buried in there
there is a underlining Gen Z the Zoomers
I think are very open to embrace an on
Apple product in the US because Apple to
them is the [ __ ] establishment and I
think Samsung has the most permission
they did a lot of smart stuff with Casey
like that I think that they need to go
back to those roots that I think they've
got away from here a little bit because
they went on defense with the phone on
fire
and I think I think they go on offense
like I would make a commercial it's like
you know you think our [ __ ] phone was
on fire last time we're really on fire
now look at this I would literally come
out with something called the Samsung
fire own your own [ __ ] joke taken
like take own your own [ __ ] joke it's
my favorite move in high school I'm
gonna make fun of you for braces own it
they're gonna make fun of you for acne
own it once you take it from them
you own it they don't and so that's what
I would do if I'm Samsung I would
literally come out with the best
innovative phone we could possibly put
out go
project fire and then just [ __ ] own
the whole fire story these are really
good ideas Jesus so I think fashion
brands need to really think about
collaborations youth culture a lot of
tik-tok a lot of finding their off-white
their Shawn you know they're there
Kendrick there Kendrick there Kanye
there you know Travis Scott
there you know Joey fresh they like they
need to find collaborations because I
don't think just sneakers I think
there's a crazy collaborate
collaboration with Calvin Klein and a
very attractive man and woman for their
underwear like we saw with Marky Mark
back it and Kate Moss back in a day I
think a real heavy collab with like
whoever the kind of cultural 20 year old
sex symbols are but not the way they've
done it for last eight to ten years
where it's like Bieber or hailey will be
the face of the brand no no I mean like
collab where like all of sudden we've
seen the first innovation on underwear
like the band is different where the
pockets are different or like you know
like just something neat that is
collabed with a creative director that
is that person and like you know it
that's what I would probably do and I
would really focus on tick tock if I was
Calvin Klein I think winning youth
culture when you're that kind of brand
is imperative if you are a fashion brand
that markets to 30 and under you should
be spending an uncomfortable amount of
your money on tick tock
innovate but they haven't done that
that's my biggest scrape with their
current CEO [ __ ] enemy videogames - I
can't believe apples not a real player
now if jobs are still around they
probably have a standalone handheld
console that [ __ ] blew everybody's
mind like a switch for the [ __ ] 26
year olds because that's what he [ __ ]
did hey guys as a Tom Sherman I'm an
entrepreneur
Gary's one of my best friends for 15
years the owner of made New York Pizza
hunt fish club White Horse Tavern so
you're gonna see a video now of all of
us in Paterson New Jersey last week so
Gary and I took a trip out there we went
to see our friends DJ envy his partner
Cesar Pina and we took our friend DJ
Clue with us envy and Cesar are doing
these wonderful wonderful seminars where
they're teaching their community how to
invest in themselves how to invest in
real estate kind of demystifying the
process of real estate ownership so many
people seem to think that it's beyond
their grasp to own their own properties
and to own their own apartments and
their own homes and they're really show
they're kind of breaking that myth
they're showing people how ownership is
possible even with low to medium incomes
Gary and I found that really interesting
go to clue we want to take a trip out
there and see what they're doing and
take a look at some of these communities
and see about you know maybe investing
in these projects because it's really
interesting to us to invest in these
properties that provide you know housing
opportunities for people that are
starting out just like we did all these
years ago so you saw a lot of great
things we're thinking really heavily
about getting into this and watch the
video for me personally with everything
I heard because I've never been a
conservative investor I my conservative
part of my life is me the human and my
business and then I'm investing I've
been actually a pretty hardcore gambler
high-risk high-reward the one thing that
has my attention quite a bit here is
there's two things one is jersey itself
Jersey itself as a Jersey boy is kind of
on my mind as I'm going to this next
chapter
- I think jerseys next when it comes to
Brooklyn
so like Maplewood got crazy in the last
decade right so one of the things that
I'll be looking for in this process
besides really trying to help like in
any way I can actually this is all a
very warm room obviously starting the
most with him is do I think Rutherford
is the next Bushwick or which one is it
Newark is really interesting to me the
bones of Newark can hold 600,000 people
it's at 3:30 that's interesting to me
like and then I just haven't done the
homework and obviously you guys have
done a lot more like what's the there's
a little part of me that's like what
makes it fun for me is just deciding
it's the caucus and then just making
Secaucus
[Music]
[Music]
you know 5:00 a.m. wake up
4:38 was a five eight five a m-- wake up
Atlanta less nobody flew in quick shower
several calls meetings without the
Patterson New Jersey on some secret [ __ ]
now going to a meeting with a potential
client CEO and an APM workout dear uncle
trying to remind me get a little iPhone
video for the workout and that will be
our Monday most people checked out on
this Presidents Day I'm just not about
that Abraham Lincoln George Washington
[ __ ] can't say Washington [ __ ] work
[Music]
[Music]
so you do all these things for kids
raised in a better environment that you
were raised in you've given him more
things and then you see all these DMS
from these kids and they actually resent
it with it it would it would make the
majority of people that are listening
right now that are high net-worth and
are paying for kids stuff if they're 14
to 25 it would make them shiver at their
core to know what their kids actually
think of them as a matter of fact here's
a credible thing this was a very
emotional moment for me yesterday I was
at the gym yesterday at 8:30 p.m. you
know cuz I was in Atlanta in the morning
couldn't do my normal workout it it's
Presidents Day weekend so nobody was in
you know 8:30 p.m. in the gym right here
at Equinox across my office and not a
lot of people there this big dude it was
really funny talk about admiration on
both sides this huge bulky guy big butt
big thighs he's like throwing up like
125 sound like arms anyway sure enough
I'm leaving and he grabs me is okay big
fan you know you know just wanted to ask
you you know do you have any business
any job opportunities and before I could
say anything he goes you know I don't
want to lie to you like and he looks 27
to me look which means he's 24 to 32 he
says to me you know my diploma I am in
bodybuilding and fitness
you know I've competed I'm from Spain my
and I don't want to lie to you like my
parents are been taking care of me and I
don't want to do that anymore and when I
tell you my heart yeah like yeah it
meant so much to me like it not only
does it get it because he was a fan and
knew my stuff that I am saying and
talking about things that very few
people are talking about because I'm
reading these comments and I'm making
observations that I don't think are
obvious nonetheless
what to your question
[Music]
these kids resent their parents and
believe that they can't do anything they
are 100% zoo animals you go take the
biggest tiger in the in the zoo of any
zoo in America right now and you put her
him in the wild they're dead in a minute
and that's the children were raising
we're taking care of them there so I
keep telling good kids like you've got
the advantage
you think if the machine is suppressing
you but the internet flipped it because
the internet doesn't know our
backgrounds it's just like if you make
music if you make content if you make
t-shirts like they don't know what if
you're good there's nobody stopping you
the system used to be against you now
it's like reverse now College the
parents dad's friend has a job waiting
for the kid cool but like as somebody
who's been on the other side of that
that kids going nowhere in that
organisation the kid knows it the
biggest thing that parents are
delusional to is kids know they know
their resume they know they're in the
zoo and they're mad at the people that
built the zoo and the person that built
a zoo is their parents hi everyone my
name is Tina and I'm a project
management paid media buyer and at team
dairy now I'm going to show you what's
on my desk
let's go so this is my corner that's
Gary's office it's generally super
hectic but I'm gonna show what's on my
desk I want to start on with as a Star
Wars geek with my bb-8 huge Star Wars
guy as you guys know just pulling from
opposite directions we have a BB 9 e and
a BB it you can't just have good yeah I
gotta have both
let's get out of here on to the next one
we have this I'm a clean guy as you can
see it's all clean so we have this
garyvee it's a mindset game because it
is a mindset game and you got a clean
your ship and this is a fan-made Lego of
me with vaynermedia sign on it I don't
know how much you guys care about me I
think I have one friend I think my mom
sent this but it looks pretty good the
last part is I'm again the health geek
so this is chlorella if I had something
weird I don't want to get sick so I just
bring my chlorella if you know what this
is you can DM
last one again I said there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on around here so I got to
close my ears and like as gary says
Jason can play the clip I can't hear you
you got to play this I can't hear you so
you got to focus can't hear you and the
last part this is a very very important
part I am my basketball so when I'm
bored I just play around with it and if
I just want to move around I can do this
it's a standing desk you move around if
you're bored you just walk around [ __ ]
around with Jason you say what's up to
Gary and then this is my desk and
hopefully it's the best desk forever
episode 7 my lucky number you know
everything that I showed you is really
valuable to me so if you around the
office please don't steal my [ __ ] thank
you for having me yeah I mean he's
always 24/7 - real pleasure yeah we're
we're we got the best gig he loves this
cultural morning breathing as do i and
like we don't want anything from nobody
that's what everyone's like why is this
happening like you know different people
business people even the labels they're
like why is it [ __ ] with you I'm like
cuz I don't want anything from them
you're trying to sign them and on their
life I'm trying to [ __ ] put money and
exposure in their pocket you're like it
doesn't work obligated yeah like listen
if I decide I want to I won't be scared
to do it and by this by the way if the
more love you give that by the time we
do that everyone's gonna want to come
but I'm not even thinking about that
right now we like being agnostic that's
why 137 so big for us we're about to
make that like I promise like the
freshmen list or other [ __ ] like give us
24 months everyone's gonna be one
because it lets us scale
cuz I'm busy I don't get to do this that
much but like if we want to give love to
key Glock or something or you like we
got a platform now to do it at scale hey
a bunch of b-roll I'm sure it tastes
Tuesday yeah Tuesday good day of
operational meetings not much else to
say good day five o'clock just [ __ ]
[Music]
idea where was it that anymore
let's [ __ ] just log what's good don't
have any video person with me I'm in LA
no I'm good
I've to have some meetings just had a
senior leadership meetings join me for
meeting just keeping it updated blog
life what what's up vlog just had a
bunch of meetings in the office super
productive day operation lost two hours
with the UH leadership team here like
four or five other meetings any kind of
meetings just um and the meetings of
friends new friends heading to a client
thing with 137 p.m. in pure wild calm
for gallery media group and just excited
just kind of live in the entrepreneurial
executive life like I do which is fun
and I'm gonna enjoy your weekly beam I
really appreciate that you guys are
enjoying it I could see that it's
bringing a lot of value to a lot of
people see a lot of people talking about
getting back on the Gary B train which
is a lot of fun you're always trying to
eliminate friction from your end user
and I think weekly be is bringing a lot
of value so thank you and I'll keep
doing it
[Music]
she's had a really good meeting with a
bunch of our feeder sports athletes and
going to airport after I see that blog
on my way now to quit the platform you
maybe saw the Superbowl ads I've been
hearing about it just like in the
Boehner exa offices
[Music]
so let's roam going and having to import
a couple hours at least been productive
kind of managing managing my world right
now through email and texts and phone
calls I do that quite a bit
so it's meeting life but on the road
instead of in my office
alright just got done with liquidity
meeting I can't tell you [ __ ] about it
nothing I can't tell you anything about
it blog zero zero zero zero
hey it's my voice from the Monday to
Monday podcasts and playlists and what
you're about to watch is a meeting Gary
had with pink sweats last week there's a
lot of us Phyllis who have more money
than me but I'm the entrepreneur you
know I'm your entrepreneur Stanford
entrepreneur you know they kind of thing
like I want the admiration I want to
bring the most value even what we're
doing with music stuff every day fine I
mean you must get it cuz I'm busy doing
a lot of [ __ ] every day
I get three people mooning police say so
what you really do it you know like
everybody thinks we're up to an album
everything's a record label everybody
thinks four I'm like given love give
them love to one of the four things that
matter in society karma that's tiny
growth I think so
and like I'm an entrepreneur like in 13
years old like oh [ __ ] I'm TV went out
of business I'm gonna find out who
branded reboot it I'm not against it but
it's definitely not
I mean everybody's transition you know
the rule in the worst place let me be
the most time tell you one fifteen to
twenty five-year-old in America that
[ __ ] with that to be heavy it's finding
that book about the worst place music is
a tough place right now especially for
like magazines fader and everything like
that's fine that that just because
that's like saying like they said that
well that person sucks something yeah
that person such - have you ever zoom
just fine sure like it you know it sound
cloud rappers or pop it every day like
you know yeah you know what I mean yeah
I think for me it's that's the kind of
brand that has to do something like Fela
we're champion you know like what are
they at somebody in the next 50 years
whether it's tomorrow or 31 years from
now is gonna take it do it proper yeah
MTV should be Spotify people don't get
how it actually works not a nice one no
idea
MTV urban master MTV should have been
spotted I was stuck they were stopped by
the way we think happens to artists good
stuff they have one album in its
original beat
at the airport
[ __ ] dealt the life headed to New
York
refinishing sin health disease research
for more than 7 57 mm
[Music]
Hey
I got two seconds uh have you gotten
into yet nope okay so what we're gonna
talk about a little bit today I mean you
guys are without me is I really really
need to fix vaynermedia to be like team
Gary and so somebody I mean I think
you're seeing a lot of you know smoke on
this so in the most awesome safe way I'm
trying to decide who in this room needs
to go and be in the creative department
at Vayner and you need to decide if
that's good for you or if you're excited
about back and so I've already had some
subtle conversations I've already been
game planning on my very ivory-tower
point of view of like watching you guys
from afar it's a pretty epic opportunity
from this standpoint what you have to
kind of decide is like I'm gonna try to
make it as unbelievable for you as
possible because you're my inner circle
of like is there value to go in there
for 18 to 24 months is there the option
to then come back what I will say is if
you're gonna Andy we'll go through and
we'll go through it all together if you
go in it's gotta be minimum 12 months
like if you go there to month and you're
like bah I didn't realize how awesome it
was like I thought I hated it but I love
Sid like he's way better than Rick you
know like that kind of stuff so but I
definitely need to impact the agency and
the best way for me to do that is to
impact it with the people that [ __ ]
though and guess what you're the people
that know so it's not like like if
you're like super pumped about it you're
not going to hurt like this so all one
family so like I I'm saying this because
I don't want you to be scared be like
yeah and be like oh did Gary give it
like I pumped either way I think there's
a real impact that's all and you can
make and this is like really important
moment like veiners on the cusp and the
thing that spanners missing is a
creative department that looks like you
at the maker level that goes up for a
lot of you like i for a lot of you i
think this could be a huge opportunity a
lot of learnings you know we talk like
it's a lot slower out there than it is
here you could you know I the other
thing is it can lead to a career path
that
might be something you want you know
like you guys know from my perspective
everybody just needs to find their
happiness if your happiness is to be a
creative director in the number one
creative agency in the world in six
years and make 290 or 320 then let me
tell you right now you better really
consider this one right now because
that's gonna be by far the easiest path
to that so really exciting time like
didn't want to I wanted to jump in
because I didn't why do you can't I
didn't want somebody else to deliver the
news of like hey I'm probably in a
mental place right now where I'm okay
with more than half of this team going
into the machine because we need it and
I think your impact could be enormous
and I think for 70% of that group it
could be disproportionately the right
thing to do and last night I was
thinking I'm like let me create a
trigger that also if they're 50/50 which
probably at some level everyone could be
what's the trigger of like okay
twelve minimum most likely eighteen
months you can come back if you want
what does that mean
very frankly it you know they're no
question there's probably some pay bump
that comes along with that
going into the machine so that's some
real talk to and you can have that time
with me so that's that's the gist so
cool
[Music]
what are holes in your [ __ ] it shut that
was fun you know what you know what it
is I care about I care about people I
care about I'm comfortable in my
environment that's how I like to
communicate plenty people get frustrated
with me of like you're interrupting this
and that but I also like yeah I know you
don't I care about like some on me so
somebody doesn't like the interrupting
the good news is like I said in the
podcast today there's unlimited options
I know there's a lot of people who
actually learn this way and in that
chaos is the breakthrough continue your
work thank you really
it's [ __ ] a real brill a lot to take
in you will I'm great good man thank you
so much for the opportunity to come here
or this place is awesome cool right yeah
give it time for a questions with us go
ahead yeah I wrote it down so no worries
so I want to know what is the right
balance between spending money on things
you like versus giving back to the
people that have impacted your life or
whose lives you like you get to make
that decision
it's no different than the coin don't
let anybody judge you you want to buy a
[ __ ] pirates you want it by a pirates
Jersey epic you want to give back to
your hands because she helped you epic
there is no wrong call there's only your
call my god the fact that you even ask
the question means you're intense in a
good place you've actually already won
that game now take all the opinions out
and it's over thank you welcome hey if
you want a bigger challenge and win the
Super Bowl please please my the pirate I
gotta go in this meeting thank you so
much you're welcome to 101 oh I love it
so good the vibe everything I don't I've
never told this story I no question in
the history of my life the apex of my
athletic ability is literally baseball I
actually have to go to Colonia New
Jersey I threw out eight people in a
little league game and they put a plaque
in my room in the in the clubhouse and
high school I went and it was still
there uh I will literally literally this
summer the three of us Lewis Pat will
will make some baseball content yeah
Friday good week you know didn't have a
film person with me a lot of this week
super weird hope this was a good week
levy for you guys you know it's like you
know these videos I make for this it's
kind of like I don't know like I can
work it like I hope that it's showing
how much of an executive I am at some
level because I think it helps being a
fuller picture like I'm thrilled to be a
motivational speaker an entrepreneur a
[ __ ] investment but like I'm an
operator and I love that and so it's
what I do all the time always I'm good
you had don't need more
don't apologize we're in the studio with
the guy or chopping we ordered with
channeling we order some chicken wings
we're feeling delicious
[Music]